hey youtubers is Charlie so because the
season 4 finale is this weekend I wanted
to rank all the previous finales and
just take some time to re-examine them
and see you know what I really liked or
if I've changed my mind about anything
and to try to put them into a larger
context of the series in the books we
can totally do that for Season 4
starting next week but for now let's
just focus on the final episodes we've
seen so far if you're finding me for the
first time I do Game of Thrones videos
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I do review videos q and A's bonus
videos so I'm also doing a special
giveaway whenever I post my episode 10
review this Sunday so this is how we're
gonna do this we're just gonna rank each
of the previous finales and try to put
them into a larger context and see how
the show is changing things from the
books so careful for spoilers from
everything from seasons 1 to 3 if you
haven't seen any of those episodes yet
but here we go my number 3 finale the
season 3 finale there was so much that
happened in this episode but I feel like
everyone still remembers it as red
wedding aftermath it's like the finale
episodes each season are victims of the
9th episode
oh moments everyone still got like
this fear hi from red wedding fumes and
everything that Jon Snow and Daenerys
does in the east just feels like a
letdown
at no point did I ever feel like any of
the moments in the season 3 finale were
wasted it's just that the red wedding
was such a cultural landmark for
television there was no way they were
gonna top that until we got the season 4
there were a few graphic moments that
stood out just because they were so
awful yar and balon greyjoy opening that
box with fianc you know quote-unquote
favorite toy Robb Stark's body with gray
wins head on it those were things that
stuck with me but mostly just because
they were so graphic so the big reason
that I made the season 3 finale my
number 3 pick is really because I felt
like the red wedding should have been
the final episode they should have used
that as like the final oh my god then
cut to black there were so many other
important foreshadowing moments like
brand passing north of the wall Sam and
maester aemon sending the Raven to
Stannis about the White Walkers I
actually think that my favorite moment
from the finale had nothing to do with
Daenerys and nothing to do with you know
Theon in the box it was really sore
Davos letting Gendry go at Dragonstone
not just because Gendry is a fan
favorite and everyone wants them to find
ari again but because i believe there is
a divine plan for everyone at least in
the story and people survived for a
reason it's not just
the writers or George or Martin doing
things randomly so Guidry rowing away
from Dragonstone isn't just like a
random act of kindness it's like the
universe inside Game of Thrones or A
Song of Ice and Fire however you want to
think about it saying you are too
important to die you're part of a larger
plan yes Dan and Dave have changed
George RR Martin's plan a little but
largely I think that the books in the
show will end at the same point they'll
just get there in slightly different
ways and after the credits rolled I
could not stop thinking about what the
show was gonna do with Gendry because it
has changed his character from the books
so much we spent most of season four
still wondering what's going on with him
they could fold the mummer's dragon
story into his he could head east
enjoying the golden company or he could
run into Aria somewhere else I can't
stop thinking about it
and supposedly Joe Dempsie tweeted that
he got to work with Maisie Williams this
year because his character has changed
so much from the books we can't really
predict what's gonna happen with him so
I'm just gonna keep my eyes peeled on my
television just make sure you don't
leave your television until the credits
rolled or black on to my second favorite
finale the season 2 finale yes this
followed Blackwater but I don't feel
like the contrast between episodes was
as great as it was during season 3 so it
was a lot easier for the holy crap
moments to stand out like Arya getting
the Braavosi coin the army of White
Walkers Theon at Winterfell and Daenerys
in the house of the undying I really do
feel like Daenerys in the house the
undying was a much more important moment
than that army of White Walkers even
though the White Walkers were like a
bigger WTF the House the undying scenes
were part of the biggest group of
prophecies on the show I did a video
about my favorite ones but they're like
over 50 in the series the house the
undying just comprises the largest
single concentration of them so far that
is i fully expect george RR martin to
pay off all those prophecies that he set
up in the house the undying and I'm
pretty sure the show is gonna do it too
just because it costs so much to do
things on television that you really
don't see people teasing things that big
that they do not pay off just for
reference here's some of the biggest
prophecies that came out of the house
the undying there's the dragon has three
heads which I know everyone is really
excited about there's mother of dragons
three fires you miss light and daughter
of death so I'm going to add a link in
the description for that other prophecy
bonus video I did I just go into much
greater detail about some of these
prophecies and on to my number one Game
of Thrones finale
obviously season
I know it seems weird the way I rank
these like they're getting worse as we
go along but that's not true it's just
that in the greater context of the
series in the books the season 1 finale
had a much greater impact than the
season 2 & 3 finales I'm really hoping
this year's the season 4 finale changes
that it's really all about this you know
episode 10 season 1 is when dragons came
back into the world it was like Daenerys
was proving that magic does exist up to
that point in the show there really
wasn't a lot of proof that there was
anything different about Game of Thrones
than any other regular period story
Westeros without magic and Dragons could
totally be a medieval Western Europe but
Dragons coming back changes all that it
opens the door for shadow babies White
Walkers and stranger knows what else to
be fair though the season one and two
finales in my mind were fairly equally
amazing but I chose season 1 as my
favorite just because of Daenerys I
think that's the scene that made her
character so popular for fans of the
show
HBO started using her face Mord more to
market it even though Tyrion in my mind
is a more important character that could
always change as we get more books and
more seasons of the show some other
character could rise up is like the new
fan favorite or the new most important
character but I feel like Daenerys naked
with dragons is what you tell people
when you want them to watch the show
like if you ever wanted to convince one
of your friends to watch it that knows
nothing about Game of Thrones just send
them this picture and that's all they
need but now it's your turn let me know
in the comments below which season
finale has been your favorite so far and
what do you want to see in the season 4
finale I'll remind everyone please use
spoiler tags whenever you're commenting
if you've read the books supposedly Kit
Harington was saying there would
definitely be a surprise at the end he
didn't say what it was but make sure you
do not leave your television until the
episode cuts to black I'm really just
hoping that they keep the theme of Ice
and Fire when they do the finales and we
end on a moment in the north it could
either be something with bran or
something with Jon Snow I'm not
expecting a big white Walker surprise
moment just because we got that one
during episode 4 but that's also a
possibility
here's that the rest of my Game of
Thrones video schedule is gonna work
this week Sunday I'm gonna do a bonus
video explaining who the children of the
forest are be sure to subscribe to get
it then I'm gonna post my finale review
after the episode airs and on Monday I'm
gonna post my season 5 predictions video
and then do a finale Q&A
so after that I'll just do a couple more
bonus videos during the week I'm not
exactly sure what those videos are gonna
be yet but in about two weeks I'm just
gonna start doing weekly bonus videos on
Sundays so feel free to leave me
suggestions about topics you guys want
to talk about you know things from the
books things from the show anything at
all so right now click here to learn
more about the biggest prophecies on the
show and click here to get that children
of the forest video all the annotation
as soon as I post it thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you